and so people had a lot of expectations
about the parade and especially his
speech regarding mobilization whether
president putin will call this a war
whether or not for example he will call
for victory and in a way the surprising
thing was that he didn't talk about much
it was kind of quite a defensive speech
the focus was mainly on dumbass
and on themes that you know
the russia had no choice but to get
involved in the war in ukraine there was
also an important mention of the fact
that for example the children and family
of the fallen soldiers in ukraine will
get compensation
that they are sort of fighting a
patriotic cause and you know they're
making their ancestors sort of proud but
it was not the mumbastic and eventful
speech that
a lot of the commentators were expecting
the speech was quite short but the
coverage that the russians saw was
actually you know last the whole morning
and was very extensive and there were
the rank links between past and sort of
present on the russian tv before the
parade started and so the soldiers sort
of themselves created this hypothetical
historical link between the fighting of
nazism in 1945
and what they're doing today in 2022.
commentators including myself were
interested in looking and seeing a
number of things for example the state
of health of president britain himself
right there has been a lot of discussion
about him being ill
and in that sense you know we could all
well see that prison was in good enough
health the second focus we had was on
the defense minister there were lots of
rumors about shoigu being ill
having had heart attacks and again a lot
of the interest was on whether or not
choigo would essentially be able to
stand up for the entire parade and again
we saw that he was capable of doing that
the interesting thing that we saw was
the way that britain actually then sat
down surrounded by the veterans
and in that way
putin has been trying to position
himself and to create this physical link
between him and the veterans of the
great patriotic war by being placed
between and amongst them now putin
himself actually doesn't have much of
military experience for all that he was
part of the fsb you know he's not an
army man and there's been a lot of
criticism levied against him that he
basically doesn't know much about the
conduct of war we still don't know
what president putin ultimately wants as
the end goal
and the conclusion to the war in ukraine
and i think in that sense neither the
russian public nor the western
commentators
have found out anything about it
in practice
[Music]
you